All
right,
this is.
OK.
This is CS 50,
Harvard University's introduction to the intellectual Enterprises of
Computer Science and the arts of programming.
My name is David Malan,
and this is week er,
and by the end of today you'll know not only what these light bulbs here spell,
but so much more.
But why don't we start first with the,
uh,
the elephant or the elephant in the room,
that is artificial intelligence,
which is seemingly everywhere over the past few years,
and it's been said that it's going to change programming,
and that's absolutely the case.
It's been that way actually for the past several years.
is only going to get to be the case all the more,
but this is an incredibly exciting time.
This is actually a good thing,
I do think insofar as now using AI in any number of forms,
you can ask the computer to help solve some problem for you.
You can find some bug or mistake in your code.
Better still,
increasingly you can tell the AI what additional
features you want to add to your software,
and this is huge because even in the industry for years,
humans have been programming in some form for decades,
building products and solutions to problems.
The
is that you and I as humans have long been the bottleneck.
There's only so many hours in the day.
There's only so many people on your team or in your company,
and there's so many more bugs that you want to solve
and so many more features that you want to implement.
But at the same time you still really need to understand the fundamentals.
And indeed a class like this,
CS 50,
has never been about teaching you how to program.
Like that's actually one of the side effects of taking a class like this,
but the overarching goal is to teach you how to think,
how to take input and produce.
Correct output and how to master these and other tools.
And so by the end of the semester,
not only,
not only will you be acquainted with languages like Scratch,
which we'll touch on today if you've not seen it already,
languages like C and Python and SQL,
HTML CSS and JavaScript,
you'll be able to teach yourself new things ultimately and ultimately be able
to tell computers increasingly what it is you want it to do,
but you'll still be in the driver's seat,
so to speak.
You'll be the pilot,
you'll be the conductor,
whatever your preferred metaphor.
And that's what I think is so empowering still about learning
introductory material,
foundational material,
because you'll know what you're ultimately talking about
and what you can in fact solve.
We've been through this before,
like when calculators came out,
it's still valuable,
I dare say all these years later to still
know how to do addition and subtraction and whatnot.
And yet I think back on some of my own math classes,
I remember learning so many darn ways in
college how to take derivatives and integrals.
And after like the 6th process of that,
I sort of realized,
OK,
I get it.
I get the idea.
Do I really need to know this many ways?
And here too,
with AI and with code,
can you increasingly sort of master the ideas and then lean on a copilot,
assistant to actually help you solve those same problems.
So let's do some of this ourselves here.
In fact,
just to give you a teaser of what you'll be able to do yourselves before long,
let me go ahead and open up a little something called Visual Studio Code,
AKA VS code for short.
This is popular,
largely open source or free software that's used by real world people.
In industry to write code and it's essentially a text editor similar to notepad,
if you're familiar with that or text edit,
kind of like Google Docs,
but no bold facing and underlining and things like
that that you'd find in word processing programs.
And this is CS 50's version thereof.
We're going to introduce you to this all the more next week,
but for now,
let's just give you a taste of what you can do with an environment like this.
So I'm going to switch over
to this program already running VS code,
and in this bottom of the screen,
you're going to see a so-called terminal.
Window again,
more on that next week,
but it's in this terminal window that I can write commands
that tells the computer what I want it to do.
For instance,
let's suppose just for the sake of discussion that I want to make my own chatbot,
not Chat GPT or Gemini and Claw.
Like,
let's make our own in some sense.
So I'm going to code up a program called chat.ie,
and you might be familiar that I,
I'm using a language here.ie is it's just called Python,
and if unfamiliar,
you're in good company.
You'll learn that too within a few weeks.
And at the top.
File here I can write my code and at the bottom of
the file of the window here I can run my code.
So here's how relatively easy it is nowadays to write even
your own chatbot using the AI technologies that we already have.
I'm going to go ahead and type a command like import.
I'm going to go ahead and type the following
from OpenAI,
import OpenAI.
We'll learn what this means ultimately,
but what I'm going to do is write my own program on top of.
An API application programming interface that someone
else provides a big company called OpenAI,
and they're providing features and functionality that
now I can write code against.
I'm going to create a so-called client,
which is to say a program of my own
that's going to use this OpenAI software.
And then I'm going to go ahead and ask this software for a response,
and I'm going to set that equal to client.pos.create,
whatever all that means,
and then Inside of these parentheses,
I'm going to say
the following.
The input I want to give to this underlying API is quote unquote something like
in one sentence,
what is CS 50?
Much like I would ask Chachi PT itself.
If you're familiar with things like Chat GPT and AI more generally nowadays,
you know,
there's this thing called models which are like statistical
models that ultimately drive what the AI's can do.
I'm gonna go ahead and say model equals quote unquote GPT 5,
which is the latest and greatest version at least as of today.
Now down in my terminal window I'm going to run a different command,
Python of chat.ie
and so long as I have made no typographical errors in this program,
I should be able to ask OpenAI,
not with Chat GPT.com,
but with my own code
for the answer to some question.
But I want to know what the answer to that question is,
so I actually want.
Print out that response by saying print response
output text.
In other words,
these 10 lines,
and it's not even 10 lines because a few of them are blank,
I've implemented my own chatbot that at the moment is hard coded,
that is permanently configured to only answer
one question for me.
And let's see with the cross of the fingers.
CS 50 is Harvard University's introductory computer science course,
the intellectual enterprises of Computer Science and the Art of programming.
Weirdly familiar,
covering problem solving algorithms,
data structures,
and more using languages like CPython and SQL.
OK,
interesting,
but let's make the program itself more dynamic.
Suppose you wanted to write code that actually
asks the human what their question is,
because very quickly might we want to learn
something more than just this one question.
So up here,
I'm going to go and change my code and type some.
Like this
type prompt equals
input with parentheses.
More on this another time too,
but what I'm going to ask the user for is to give me an actual prompt.
That is a question that I want this AI to answer.
And down here,
what you'll notice,
even if you've never programmed before,
is that I can do something somewhat intuitive insofar as
line 5 is now asking the human for input.
Let's just stipulate that this equal sign means store that answer
in a variable called prompt,
where variables just like in math.
Y or Z.
Let's go ahead and store that in prompt.
So the input I want to give to OpenAI now is that actual prompt.
So it's a placeholder containing whatever keystrokes the human typed in.
If I now run that same command again,
Python of chat.ie,
hit enter,
cross my fingers,
I'll see now
dynamic
prompting.
So what's the question I might want to ask?
Well,
let's just say it again in one sentence,
whoops,
in one sentence,
what is CS 50 mark?
Enter.
And now the answer comes back as
probably
roughly
the same but a little bit different,
a variant thereof,
but maybe we can distill this even more succinctly.
How about let's run it again?
Python of chat.pi and let's say in one word
what is CS 50 and see if the underlying AI obliges.
And
After a pause
course in a word,
so that's not all that incorrect,
and maybe we can have a little fun with this now.
How about in one word,
which is,
which is better?
maybe Harvard
or Stanford Question mark.
Hope you picked right.
Let's see.
The answer is.
Depends.
OK,
so would not in fact oblige,
but notice what I keep doing in this code.
I keep providing a prompt as the human like in one sentence,
in one word.
Well,
if you want the AI to behave in a certain way,
why don't we just tell the underlying system to behave in that way
so why the human don't have to keep asking it in one sentence,
in one sentence in one word,
so we can actually introduce one other feature
that you'll hear discussed in industry nowadays,
which is not only
a prompt from the user,
which I'm gonna.
Now temporarily renamed to user prompt just to make clear it's coming from the user.
I'm going to also give our what's called a system prompt by setting this equal to some
standardized instructions that I want the AI
to respect,
like limit your answer to one sentence,
quote unquote.
And now in addition to passing in as input,
the user prompt,
I'm going to actually tell OpenI.
to use these instructions coming from this other variable
called System prompt.
So in other words,
I'm still using the same underlying service,
but I'm handing it now not only what the user typed in,
but also this standardized text limit your answer to one sentence
so the human like me doesn't have to do that anymore.
Let's now go back to my terminal,
Run Python of chat.ie once more,
and this time we'll be prompted,
but now I can just ask what is CS 50 question.
And
I'll likely get
a correct and similar
answer to before.
And indeed it's Harvard University's
flagship introductory computer science course.
So it seems spot on too.
But now we can have some fun with this too,
and you might know that these GPTs nowadays have sort of personalities.
You can make them obliged to behave in one way or another.
Why don't we go into our system prompt here and say something silly like pretend
you're a cat.
And now let's go back to the prompt one final time.
Run Python of chat.ie
prompt again will be say what is CS 50 and with a final flourish of hitting enter.
What do we get back?
CS 50 is Harvard University's introductory
computer science course teaching programming,
algorithms,
data structures,
and problem solving,
and it's available free online
meow.
So that was enough to coerce this particular behavior.
So this is to say that with programming you have the ability in like 10 lines of text,
not all of which you might understand yet,
but that's the whole point of a class like this to build fairly powerful things,
maybe silly things like this,
but in fact it's using the same primitives that CS 50 has its own.
Virtual rubber duck and we'll talk more about this in the weeks to come,
but long story short,
in the world of programming,
it's kind of a thing
to keep a rubber duck literally on your desk or really any inanimate
cute object like this because when you are struggling with some problems,
some bug or mistake in your code and you don't have a friend,
a teaching assistant,
a parent,
or someone else who's more knowledgeable than you.
About code where you literally are encouraged in programming
circles to like talk to the rubber duck,
and it's through that process of just verbalizing your confusion
and organizing your thoughts enough to convey it to another person or duck in
this case that so often that proverbial light bulb goes off and you realize,
ah,
I'm being an idiot now I hear in my own thoughts the illogic or the mistake I'm making.
And you solve that problem as well.
So CS 50,
drawing inspiration from this,
will give to you a virtual duck in computer form.
And in fact,
among the other URLs you'll use over the course of the semester is that here,
CS50.AI,
which is also built into that previous URL,
CS50.
dev,
whereby these are the AIs you can use in CS50
to solve problems and you are encouraged to do so.
As you'll see in the course of syllabus,
it is not reasonable.
Not allowed to use AI-based software other than CS 50's own,
be it Claw,
Gemini,
Chachi PT,
or the like,
but it is reasonable and very much encouraged along the
way to turn not only to humans like me,
your teaching assistant,
and others in the class,
but to CS 50's own AI-based software.
And what you'll find is that this virtual duck is designed to behave as close to a good
human tutor as you might expect from an actual human in the real world knows about CS.
knows how to lead you to a solution,
ideally without simply spoiling it and providing it outright.
So with that said,
that's sort of the end game to be able to write code like that and more.
But let's really start back at the beginning and see how we can't get
from zeros and ones that computers speak
all the way back to artificial intelligence.
So computer science is in the name of the course,
Computer Science 50,
but what is that?
Well,
it's really Just the study of information.
How do you represent it?
How do you process it?
and very much germane to computer science
is what the world calls computational thinking,
which is just the application of ideas from computer science,
or CS to problems generally in the real world.
And in fact that's ultimately,
I dare say what computer science really is.
It's about problem solving and even though we use computers,
you learn how to program along the way,
these are really just tools and methodologies.
that you can leverage to solve problems.
Now what does that mean?
Well,
a problem is perhaps most easily distilled into a simple picture like this.
We've got some input,
which is like the problem we want to solve,
and the output,
which is the goal we want the solution there too.
And then somewhere in the middle here is the proverbial black box,
the sort of secret sauce that gets that input
from output.
So this then I would say is in essence is problem solving
and thus computer science.
But we have to agree,
especially if we're going to use devices,
Macs,
PCs,
phones,
whatever,
how do we all represent information,
the inputs and the outputs in some standardized way?
Is it with English?
Is it with something else?
Well,
you all probably know,
even if you're not computer people,
that at the end of the day
computers somehow use zeros in one entirely.
That is their entire alphabet.
And in fact
you might be familiar already with certain such systems.
So the unary notation,
which means you essentially use single digits like fingers on your hand,
for instance,
unary AKA base one,
is something you can do on your own human hand.
So for instance,
with one human hand,
how high can I count?
All right,
so hopefully 12345,
and if you want to count to 6 to 11 and 10 and so forth,
you need to,
you know,
take out another hand or your toes or the like because it's fairly limiting.
But if I think a little harder instead of just using unary,
what if I use a different system instead?
What about something like binary?
Well,
how high if you think a little harder,
can you count on one human hand?
So 31,
says someone who studied computer science before,
but why is that?
It's kind of hard to imagine,
right?
Because 12345 seems to be the five possible patterns,
but that's only when you're looking at the totality of fingers
that are actually up 5 in total or 4 in total,
or 1 or the like.
But what if we take into account the pattern of fingers that
are up and we just standardize what each of those fingers represent?
So maybe we all agree.
Like a good computer would too,
that maybe no fingers up means the number 0.
And if we want to count to 1,
let's go with the obvious.
This is now 1.
But instead of 2 being this,
which was my first instinct,
maybe 2 can just be
this
a single second finger up like this,
and that means we could now use 2 fingers up to represent 3.
I propose we can use just one middle finger up to offend everyone but represent 4.
I could maybe use these two fingers with some difficulty to represent 567.
I'm already up to 7 having used only 3 fingers.
And in fact,
if we keep going higher and higher,
I bet I can get as high as 31 for 32 possible combinations,
but the first one was.
So that's as high as we can count.
So we'll make this connection in just a moment,
but what I started to do there is something called base 2.
Instead of just having fingers up or fingers down,
I'm taking into account the positions of those fingers
and giving meaning to like this finger here,
this finger here,
and so forth,
different weights if you will.
So
the binary system is indeed all computers.
And you might be familiar with some terminology here.
Binary digit is not really something anyone really says,
but the shorthand for that is going to be
bit.
So if you've heard of bits,
and we'll soon see bytes and then kilobytes
and megabytes and gigabytes and terabytes and more,
this just refers to a bit meaning a single
binary digit,
either a 0 or a 1.
A 0 is perhaps most simply represented by just like turning,
maybe keeping a finger down,
or in the world of computers which have access to electricity,
be it from the wall
or maybe a battery,
you know what we could do?
We could just decide sort of universally that when
a light bulb is off,
that thing represents a zero,
and when the light bulb.
Was on that thing's going to represent a 1 instead.
Now why is this?
Well,
electricity is such a simple thing,
right?
It's either flowing or it's not,
and we don't even have to therefore worry about how much of it is flowing.
If you're vaguely remember a little bit about voltage,
we can sort of be like zero volts.
Nothing's there available for us,
or maybe it's 5 volts or something else in between.
But what's nice about binary only housing zeros and ones is that it maps really
nicely to the real world by like throwing a light switch on and off.
You can represent information by just using a
little bit of electricity or the lack thereof.
So what do I mean by this?
Well,
suppose we want to start counting using binary zeros and ones only.
let's think of them metaphorically as like akin to these light.
Bulbs here and in fact let me grab a few of these light bulbs
and let me propose that if we want to represent the number 0,
well,
it stands to reason that here
single light bulb that is off can be agreed upon as representing 0.
Now in practice,
computers don't have little light bulbs inside,
but they do have little switches inside,
millions of tiny little things called transistors that have.
On can allow it to capture a little bit of electricity and
effectively turn on a metaphorical bulb or the switch can go off.
The transistor can go off and therefore let the
electricity dissipate and you have just now a 0.
Unfortunately,
even though I can let some
electricity,
here's the battery I mentioned is required,
even though we might have some electricity available to us,
I can therefore count to 1.
But how do I go about counting?
Hardware problem,
how do I go about counting higher than one
with just a light bulb?
Yeah,
so I need more of them.
So let me grab another one here,
and now I can put it next to it,
and this too I'll claim is just still the number one.
But if I want to turn 2 of them on,
well,
that would mean I could count to 2.
And if I maybe grab another one now I can count as high as 3,
but wait a minute,
I'm doing something wrong
because with 3 human fingers,
how high was they able to count.
So 7 in total starting at 0.
So I've done something wrong here,
but let me be a little more clever than about the pattern that I'm actually using.
Perhaps this can still be
1,
but just like my finger went up and only one finger in the second version of this,
this
can be what we represent as 2.
Which one do I want to turn on as 3,
your left or your right?
So you're right,
because now this matches what I was doing with my fingers a moment ago,
and I claimed we could represent 3 like this.
If we want to represent 4,
that's fine.
We have to turn that off,
this off,
and this on,
and that's somehow 4
and let's go all the way up to 7.
Which ones need to be on to represent the number 7?
All right,
so all of them here.
Now if you're not among those who just sort of naturally said
all of them,
like what the heck is going on?
How do half the people in this room know what these patterns are supposed to be?
Well,
maybe you're remembering what I did with my fingers,
but it turns out you're already pretty familiar
with systems like this,
even if you might not have put a name to it.
So in the human world,
the real world,
most of us deal every day with
the so-called base 10 system,
otherwise known as.
deck implying 10 because in the decimal system you have 10 digits available to you 0
through 9.
In the binary system we only had 2 by implying 2,
so 0 and 1.
And unary we had just 1,
a single digit there or not.
So in the decimal system we just have more of a vocabulary to play with,
and yet you and I have been doing this since grade school.
So this is obviously the number 123.
But why?
It's technically just three symbols 123,
but most of us,
your mind immediately goes,
OK,
123,
pretty obvious,
pretty natural.
But at some point you,
like me,
were probably taught that this is the one's place
and this is the ten's place and this is the 100s place and so forth.
And the reason that this pattern of symbols
123 is 123 is that we're all doing some quick mental math and.
I,
well,
that's 100 times 1 plus 10 times 2 plus 1 times 30,
OK,
there's how we get 100 plus 20 + 3 gives
us the number we all know mathematically is 123.
Well,
it turns out whether you're using decimal or binary or other
base systems that we'll talk about later in the course,
the system is still fundamentally the same.
Let's kind of generalize this away.
Here's a three digit number in some base system,
specifically in decimal,
and I know that only because of
Placeholders that I've got on top of each of these numbers.
But if we do a little bit of math here,
1,
10,
100,
1000,
10,000,
and so forth,
what's the pattern?
Well,
technically this is 100,
10 to 1,
10 to 2,
and so forth,
and we're using 10 because we can use as many as 10 digits under each of those columns.
But if we take some of those digits away and go from decimal down to binary,
the motivation being it's Way easier for
a computer to distinguish electricity being on or
off than coming up with like 10 unique levels of electricity to distinguish among.
You could do it.
It would be annoying and difficult to build and hardware you could do it
so much simpler to just say
on and off.
It's a nice simple world that way.
So let's change the base
from 10 to 2,
and what does this get us?
Well,
if we now do undo the math,
that's 2 to 0.
121 is 222 is 4.
So the the mental math is now about to be the same,
but the columns represent something a little bit different.
So for instance,
if I turn all of these off again,
such that I've got off,
off,
otherwise known as 000,
it's 0 because it's 4 times 0 + 2 times 0 + 1 times 0 still gives me 0.
By contrast,
If I turn on maybe just this one all the way over on the left,
well,
that's 4 times 1
because on represents 1 and off represents 0,
plus 2 times 0 plus 1 times 0,
that gives me 4.
And if I turn both of these on
such that all three of them are now on,
on,
AKA 111,
that's 4 times 1 plus 2 times 1 plus 1 times 1.
That then gives me 7,
and we can keep adding more and more bits to this.
In fact,
if we go all the way up
numerically,
here's how we would represent in binary the number you and I know as 0.
Here's how we would represent
1.
Here's how we would represent 2
and 3
and 4 and 5,
and you can kind of see in your mind's eyes.
Now because I only have zeros and
ones and no 2s or threes,
not to mention nines,
I'm essentially going to be carrying a 1 in a moment if we were to be doing some math.
So to go from 5
to 6,
that's why the 1 ends up in the middle column to go to 7 here gives us now 111 or on on
on,
how do I represent 8?
Using ones and zeros,
yeah,
so we're going to need to add another digit.
We need to throw hardware at the problem using an additional
digit so that we actually have a column representing 8.
Now,
as an aside,
and we'll talk about this before long,
if you don't have an additional digit available,
if your computer doesn't have enough memory,
so to speak,
you might accidentally count from 01234567.
And then accidentally
end up back at 0 because if there's no room to store
the 4th bit,
well,
all you have is part of the number,
and this is going to create all sorts of problems then ultimately in the real world.
So let me go ahead and put these back and propose that we have a system now
if you agree to sort of count numbers in this way via which we can represent
information in some standard way and all the device underneath the hood.
It is a bit of electricity to make this work.
It's got to be able to turn things on,
AKA use some transistors,
and it's got to be able to turn those things
off so as to represent zeros instead of ones.
But the reality is like 2 bits,
3 bits,
4 bits aren't very useful in the real world because even with 3 bits you can count to 7,
with 4 you can count to 15.
These aren't very big numbers,
so it tends to be more common to actually use units of measure of 8 bits at a time.
A byte is just that.
1 byte is 8 bits.
So if you've ever used the vernacular of kilobytes,
megabytes,
gigabytes,
that's just referring to some number of bits,
but
8 of them
together compose one individual byte.
So here for instance is a byte worth of bits,
8 of them total.
I've added all the additional placeholders,
and what number does this represent in decimal
even though you're looking at 8 binary digits.
It's just 0,
because like literally every column is a 0.
Now this is a bit more of mental math,
but unless you know it already,
what if I change all of the zeros to ones?
I turn all 8 light bulbs on,
what number is this?
Yeah,
so 255.
Now some of those of you who didn't get that instantly,
that's fine.
You could certainly do the math manually.
I dare say some of you have some prior knowledge of how to do this sort of system,
but 255 means
that if you start counting at 0 and you go all the way up to 255.
OK,
that's 256 total possibilities.
Once you include 0 in the total number of patterns of zeros and ones,
and this is just going to be one of these common numbers in computer science,
256.
Why?
Because it's referring to 8 of something,
2 to 8.
Gives you 256 and so you're going to commonly see certain values like that.
256 back in the day,
computers could only show 256 colors on the screen.
Certain graphics formats nowadays that you might download can
only use as many as 256 colors because,
as we'll see,
they're only using,
for instance,
8 bits and therefore they can only represent so
many colors of the rainbow as a result.
So
this
then is how we might go from just zeros and ones,
electricity inside of a computer
to storing actual numbers with which we're familiar
and honestly we can go higher than 255.
What do you need to count higher than 255?
1/9 bit,
a 10th bit,
11th bit and so forth and it turns out common conventions nowadays,
and we'll see this in code 2 is to use as many as 32 bits at a time.
So that's a good chunk of bits and anyone want to ballpark how
high you can count if you've got 32 bits available to you.
Oh,
fewer people now,
yeah,
in the back.
Yeah,
so it's roughly 4 billion,
and it's technically 2 billion if you also want to represent negative numbers,
but we'll revisit that question,
but 2 to 32nd power is roughly 4 billion.
However,
nowadays it's even more common with the Macs and PCs
you might have on your laps and even your phones nowadays
to use 64 bits,
which is a big enough number that I'm not even sure offhand how to pronounce it.
That's a lot of permutations that.
2 to 64 possible permutations,
but that's increasingly commonplace.
And as an aside,
just to dovetail things with our discussion of AI,
among the reasons that we're living through over these past few years,
especially this crazy interesting time of AI,
is because
computers have been getting so much faster,
exponentially so over time.
They have so much more memory available to them.
There's so much data out there on the internet in particular.
to train these models that it's an interesting confluence of hardware now actually
meeting the mathematics and statistics that we'll talk about later in the class
that ultimately make tools like the cat we just built possible.
But of course computers are not all math,
and in fact we'll use very little math per se in this class.
And so let's move away pretty quickly from just zeros
and ones and talk about letters of the alphabet,
say in English.
Here is the letter A.
Suppose you want to use this letter in an email,
a text message,
or any other program.
What is the computer doing underneath the hood?
How can the computer store a capital letter A in English if at the end of the
day all the computer has access to is a source of electricity from the wall or from
a battery,
and it has a lot of switches that it can turn on and off
and treat the electricity in units of 8 or 32 or 64 or whatever.
How might a computer represent a letter A?
Yeah,
we need to give it an identity,
so to speak,
as an integer.
In other words,
at the end of the day,
if your entire canvas,
so to speak,
consists only of zeros and ones,
like that is going to be the answer to every question today.
You only have zeros and ones as the solution to these problems.
We just need to agree
what pattern of zeros and ones and therefore what integer,
what number shall be used to represent the letter A.
And hopefully,
When we look at that pattern of zeros and ones in the right context,
we'll indeed see it as an A.
So if we look inside of a computer,
so to speak,
in the context of like a text messaging program
or a word processor or anything like that,
that pattern shall be interpreted hopefully as a capital letter A.
But if I open up Mac OS's or Windows or my phone's calculator program,
I would want that same pattern of zeros and ones to be interpreted instead
as a.
If I open up Photoshop,
as we'll soon see,
I want that same pattern of zeros and ones to be interpreted as a color presumably,
not to mention videos and sound and so forth,
but it's all just zeros and ones.
And so even though I,
when writing that chat program a few minutes ago,
didn't have to worry about telling the computer,
oh this is text,
this is a number,
this is something else,
we'll see as we write code ourselves that
you as the programmer will Have control over telling
the computer how to treat some pattern of zeros and ones telling it this is a number,
this is a color,
this is a letter or something else.
Um,
how do we represent the letter A?
Well,
it turns out a bunch of humans in a room years ago decided that this
pattern of zeros and ones shall be known globally as a capital letter English A.
What is that number if you do the quick mental math?
So indeed 65 because we had a 1 in the 604s place and a 1 in the one's place.
So 65,
that's just sort of it.
It would have been nice if it were just the number 1 or maybe the number 0,
but at least after the capital letter A,
they kept things consistent such that
if you want to represent a letter B,
it's going to be 66.
C,
it's going to be 67 Y because.
The humans in this room,
a bunch of Americans at the time,
standardized on what's called ASCI,
the American Standard Code for Information Interchange.
It doesn't matter what the acronym represents,
but
it was just a mapping.
Someone on a piece of paper essentially
started writing down letters of the alphabet
and corresponding numbers so that computers subsequently could all speak
that same standard representation and Here's an excerpt thereof.
In this case we're seeing 7 bits' worth,
but eventually we ended up using 8 bits in total to represent letters,
and some of these are fairly cryptic,
maybe more on those other time,
but down here if we highlight just one column,
we'll see that indeed on this cheat sheet 65 is capital A,
66 is B,
67 is C,
and so forth.
So why don't we do a little exercise here.
What
pattern of zeros and ones do I see here?
I've got 3 bytes,
so 3 sets of 8 bits,
and even though there's no placeholders now over the columns,
what is this?
Number
It's 60.
Yeah,
so we've got the 1s,
2s,
4s,
8s,
1632,
64s column.
So indeed this is going to be the number
72,
72.
This is not what computer scientists spend their day doing.
This is just to reinforce what it is we just looked at,
and I'll spoil it.
The rest of these numbers are 72,
73,
33,
and anyone in this room could have done that if you took out a piece of paper,
figured out what the columns are,
and just do a bit of quick or.
Of mental or written math,
but this is to say,
suppose that you just got a text message or an email
that if you had the ability to look underneath the hood of the computer and
see what pattern of zeros and ones did you just receive over the internet,
suppose that pattern of zeros and ones was 3 bytes of bits,
which when you do the math are the numbers 72,
73,
33.
Well,
here's the cheat sheet again.
What message did you just get?
Yeah,
so it's high.
Why?
Because 72 is H and 73 is I.
Now some of you said hi fairly emphatically why.
Well,
33 turns out you wouldn't know this unless you looked
it up or someone told you is an exclamation point.
So literally if you were to text someone like right now,
if you haven't already,
HI exclamation point in all caps.
You would essentially be sending 3 bytes of information somehow over the internet
to that recipient and because their phone similarly understands ASCI
because it was programmed years ago to do so,
it knows to show you HI exclamation point and not a number,
3 numbers no less,
or colors or something else altogether.
So here we then have high,
3 digits in a row here.
What else is worth noting here?
Well,
there's some fun
sort of trivia embedded even in this cheat sheet.
So here again is A,
and so forth,
65 on down.
Let me just highlight over here
the lowercase letters 97,
98,
99,
and so forth.
If I go back and forth,
does anyone notice
the consistent pattern between these two?
Yeah,
so the lowercase letters are 32
away
from the uppercase letters.
Well,
how do we know that?
97 minus 65 is,
yeah,
32.
98 minus 66 is OK,
32,
and that pattern continues.
What does this mean?
Well,
computers know how to do this.
Most normal humans don't need this information,
but what it means is if you are representing
in binary
with your transistors on and off representing some pattern,
and this is the pattern
representing capital letter A,
which is why we have a 1 in the 604 space and a 1
in the ones place,
how does a computer go about lower casing this same letter?
Yeah.
Perfect.
All the computer has to do is change this one bit in the 32's place to a 1,
because that has the effect mathematically per our discussion of adding
the number 32 to whatever it is.
So it turns out you can force text from upper case
to lower case or back by just changing a single bit.
Inside of that pattern
of 8 bits in total.
All right,
why don't we maybe reinforce this with another quick exercise?
We have an opportunity perhaps here for um maybe to give
you some stress balls right at the very start of class.
Could we get 8 volunteers to come up
on stage,
maybe over here
and over here and over here on the left.
Let me go all the way on the right.
Uh,
let's see.
OK,
the high hand here,
the,
the hand that's highest there,
yes,
we're making eye contact.
How about all the way,
what,
wait,
let's see,
let's go here in the crimson
sweatshirt here,
and how about in the,
the white shirt here?
Come on up.
Did I count correctly?
Let's say
Come on down.
The 8 of you.
I,
I didn't count right,
did I?
123456.
It's ironic that I'm not counting correctly here.
How about on the left in gray?
OK.
Oh,
OK,
in black here.
Come on down.
All right,
hopefully this is 81234567.
7.
I'm pretty sure.
OK,
8,
there we go.
All right.
So let's go ahead and do the following exercise.
I've got some sheets of paper preprinted here.
If each of you indeed want to do exactly what
you're doing and line up from left to right,
each of you is going to represent a placeholder essentially.
So we have over here the ones place
all the way over here,
and then we have the choose place.
And the 4th place
and the eights.
32,
64,
128,
and we come bearing a microphone.
If each of you want to say a quick hello,
your name,
maybe your dorm or house,
and something besides computer science that you're studying or want to.
Hi,
I'm out.
OK.
I'm Alison.
I'm a freshman in Mathews,
and,
um,
I like climbing and I'm thinking of CS and Econ.
2.
Hi,
I'm Lily.
I'm in Hurlbut this year and I'm thinking of doing CS in government.
Nice to meet you.
Hi,
hi,
I'm Sean.
I'm in Candidate Hall and I'm thinking of doing astrophysics and CS.
Welcome.
Hi,
I'm Jordan.
I'm doing applied math with a specialization in CS and Econ,
and,
um,
I'm in Widsworth,
and I like going to the gym.
16.
Hi,
I'm Shiv.
I'm studying Mac and I'm in Canada.
Nice.
Hi,
I'm Sophia.
I'm in Thayer and I'm thinking of doing electrical engineering.
Welcome.
Hi,
my name is Marie,
and I'm in Canada B and I really like CS physics and astrophysics.
Hi,
I'm Alyssa.
I'm in Holworthy.
I'm also thinking of studying math or physics,
and I also like to climb.
Nice.
Welcome to you all.
So on the backs of their sheets of paper,
they have a little cheat sheet that's describing what
they should do in each of 3 rounds.
We're going to spell out together a three letter word.
You all as the audience have a cheat sheet above you that represents numbers,
2 letters.
These folks don't necessarily know what they're spelling.
They only know what they individually are spelling.
So if your sheet of paper tells you to represent a zero in a given round,
just kind of stand there awkwardly,
no hands up.
But if you're told on your sheet of paper to represent a 1,
just raise a single hand to make obvious to the
audience that you're representing a 1 and not a zero.
And the goal here is to figure out what we are spelling using this system called
ASCI.
All right,
round 1,
execute.
What number is this here?
I'm hearing
you can just shout it out.
What number?
66 or B.
So you're spelling
B.
All right,
hands down.
Round 2.
More math.
Feel free to shout it out
Oh,
I heard it,
yeah,
79,
which is,
oh,
OK,
so we have BO.
Hands down,
3rd and final round,
execute.
Number
Yes,
87,
which is the letter?
W,
which spells?
Bow,
if you want to take your bow now.
Ah,
OK,
here we go.
You guys can keep those.
OK,
thank you.
All right,
you guys see that back.
Thank you to our volunteers here.
Very nicely done.
We indeed spelled out bow,
and that's just because we all standardized on
representing information in exactly the same way,
which is why when you type BOW on your phone or your computer,
the recipient sees the exact same thing.
But what's noteworthy in this discussion is that you
can't spell a huge number of words like,
yeah,
English,
OK,
we've got that covered.
But odds are you're noticing,
depending on your own background what human languages you read or speak yourself,
that a whole bunch of symbols might be missing from your keyboard.
For instance,
we have accented characters here in a lot of Asian languages.
There's so many more glyphs than we could have even
fit in that cheat sheet of numbers and letters.
And so
ASCI is not the only system that the world uses.
It was one of the earliest,
but we've moved on in modern times to a super set of AI that's generally.
Known as Unicode,
and Unicode uses so many more bits than AI that we even have room
for all of these little things that we seem to send constantly nowadays.
These are obviously images that you might send with your phone or your computer,
but they're technically characters.
They're technically just patterns of zeros and ones that have similarly
been standardized around the world to look a certain way,
but they're this is an emoji keyboard in the sense that.
You're sending
characters.
You're not sending images per se.
The characters are displayed as images,
obviously,
but really these are just like characters in a different font,
and that font happens to be very colorful and graphical as well.
So Unicode,
instead of using just 7 or 8 bits,
which if you do the quick mental math,
if Asky only used 7 or let's say 8 bits,
how many possible characters can you represent in Asky alone?
256 because if we do that quick mental math,
28,
256 possibilities like that's it.
That is,
that's enough for English because you can cram all the uppercase letters,
the lower case letters,
the numbers,
and a whole bunch of punctuation as well,
but it's not enough for certain other punctuation symbols,
not to mention many other human languages.
And so the Unicode Consortium.
Its charge in life has been to come up
with a digital representation of all human language,
past,
present,
and hopefully future by using not just 7 or 8 bits but maybe 16 bits per character,
24 bits,
or heck,
even 32 bits per character.
And per before,
if you've got as many as 32 bits available to you,
you can represent what,
like 4 billion characters in total,
and that's just one.
One of the reasons why these emoji have
kind of exploded in popularity and availability,
there's just so many darn patterns like what else are we
going to do with all of these zeros and ones.
But more importantly,
emoji have been designed to really represent people and places and
things and emotions in a way that transcends human language.
But even then they're somewhat open to interpretation.
In fact,
here's a pattern of I think 32 zeros and ones.
Guessing no one's going to do the quick mental math here,
but this represents what decimal number if we do in fact do out the
math with that's being the ones place all the way over to the left,
well,
that's the number 4 billion,
36,
991,106.
Who knows what that is?
It's not a,
and it's nothing near A upper case or lower case,
but it is among the most popular emoji that you might send typically on your phone,
laptop,
or other device,
namely.
This thing here face
with tears of joy,
which odds are you've sent or received recently,
but interestingly,
even though many of you might have iPhones and see
and send the same image,
you'll notice that if you see a friend who's got Android or some other device,
maybe you're using uh Meta's messenger program
or Telegram or some other messaging service.
Sometimes these emoji look a little bit different.
Why?
Because what a Unicode has done is they decided there shall exist
an emoji known as excuse me,
faced with tears of joy.
Then Apple and Google and Microsoft and others,
they're sort of free to interpret that as they see fit.
So what you see on the screen here is a recent version from iOS.
operating system.
Google's version of the same looks a little something like this,
and on Telegram if you have animations enabled,
the same idea faced with tears of joy is actually animated,
but it's the same pattern of zeros and ones in each case,
but again they each essentially have different graphical fonts to
present to you what each of those images actually is.
All right,
so those are each,
excuse me,
images.
So
those are each images.
How is the computer representing them though?
At the end of the day we've represented numbers,
we've represented letters,
but
how about these things here colors.
So how do we represent
red or green or blue,
not to mention every other color in between.
At the end of the day,
we only have one canvas at our disposal,
yeah.
So integers is the exact same answer as before.
We just need to agree on what number do we use for red,
what do we use for green,
what do we use for blue,
and we can come up with some standardized pattern for this.
In fact,
one of the most common techniques for doing this,
and the one of the most common ways to do this in the real
world is to use a combination of three colors together some amount of red,
some amount of green,
and some amount of blue and mix them together to get
most any color of the rainbow that you might want.
This is sort of a picture of something I grew up with back in the day where in
like middle school when we'd watch movies or some kind of show and like in in class,
we would kind of uh the projector screen would be over here.
This is an old school projector with 3 different lenses,
one of which projects some amount of green,
some amount of red,
some amount of blue,
and so long as the
lenses are correctly oriented to all point at the
same circle or like rectangular region on the screen,
you would see any number of colors coming to life in the old school.
Video.
I still remember all these years later we would kind of
sit and lean up against it because it was super warm and you could
feel it it's an easy way to fall asleep but back in grade school,
but
we use the same fundamental color system nowadays
as well,
including in modern programs like Photoshop.
So let's abstract that away,
focus on just three colors some amount of red,
green,
and blue,
and let's propose for the sake of discussion
that we want to mix together like a medium amount of red,
a medium amount of green,
and just a little bit of blue.
For instance,
Let's propose
that we'll use 72 amount of red,
23 amount of green,
or 33 amount of blue RGB.
Now why these numbers?
Well,
in the context of ASCI or Unicode,
which is just a superset thereof,
what is this spell?
Hi,
but again,
if you were instead to open a file containing
these 3 numbers or really these 3 bytes of bits
in Photoshop,
you would hope that they're going to be interpreted not as letters on the screen,
but as some the color of a dot on the screen instead.
So it turns out that in typically
when you have three of these numbers together,
each of them is using a single byte,
so 8 bits.
So you can have 0 red or 255 red,
0 green or 255 green or 0 to 255 of blue.
So 0 is none,
255 is the max.
So if we mix these together,
imagine just like that projector
consolidating these three colors into one central point.
Anyone want to guess what you're gonna get if you mix some red,
some green,
some blue in those amounts and way back?
Yeah,
you're going to get a dark shade of yellow.
I've brightened it up a little bit for the projector here,
but you're going to get it roughly this shade of yellow,
and we could play with these numbers all day long and get
similar results if we want to represent different colors as well.
And indeed,
whether it's Photoshop or some other program,
you can actually combine these amounts in all
sorts of ratios to get different colors.
So if you had 000,
so no red,
no green,
no blue,
take a guess as to what color that's going to be in the computer.
So it's gonna be black,
like the absence of all three of those colors,
but if you mix the maximal amount of each of those 255 red and green and blue,
that's gonna give you white.
Now if any of you have made web pages before or use programs like Photoshop,
you might have seen numbers like 00.
Or FF.
Long story short,
that's just another base system for representing numbers between 0 and 255 as well,
but we'll come back to that mint semester when we make some of our own
filters,
uh,
in sort of an Instagram-like way manipulating images of our own.
So where are these colors coming from or where can we actually see them?
Well,
here's just a picture of that same emoji faced with tears of joy.
If I kind of zoom in on that and maybe zoom in again,
you can start to see if you blow it up enough or
if you put your eyes close enough to the device sometimes,
you can actually see individual dots or squares.
These are generally known as pixels,
and they're just the individual dots that collectively compose in
which is to say that if each of these dots,
which is part of the image,
is going to be a distinct color like this one's yellow,
this one's brown,
and then there's a bunch in between,
well,
you're using some number of bits to represent each of those pixels' colors.
So if you imagine using the RGB system,
that's 8 + 8 + 8 bits,
so that's 24 bits
or 3 bytes,
just.
To keep track of the color of each and every one of these dots.
So now if you think about having downloaded a GIF at some point,
a ping,
PNG file,
a JPEG,
or any other file format,
it's usually measured in what file size like
megabytes typically that means millions of bytes.
Why?
Because if it's a pretty big photograph or pretty big image,
each of those dots takes up at least 3 bytes,
it would seem.
And if you do out the math,
if you've got thousands of dots,
each of which uses 3 bytes,
you're going to quickly get to megabytes,
if not even larger,
for things like,
say,
videos.
But again,
it's just patterns of zeros and ones and so long as the programmer knows what
they're doing and tells the computer how to
interpret those zeros and ones and equivalently,
so long as the software knows,
look at these zeros and ones and interpret them as numbers or letters or colors,
we should see what we intended to represent.
All right,
so that's num that's uh colors and images.
What about how many of you kind of played with
these little flip books as a kid where they've got like
100 different little pictures and you flip through them really quickly
and you see what looks like animation in book form?
Well,
this is essentially a video,
so therefore what is a video or how can you think of what a video is?
It's just a whole bunch of like images
flying across the screen either on paper or digitally
nowadays on your phone or your laptop and
that's kind of nice because we're sort of composing
more interesting media now based on these lower level
building blocks and this is going to be thematic.
We literally started with zeros and ones.
we worked our way up to letters.
We then worked our way up to sort of images and colors and thus images.
Now we're up at this level of hierarchy in terms of video because what's a video.
It's like 30 images per second flying across
the screen or maybe slightly fewer than that,
that collectively tricks our mind into thinking we are seeing motion pictures,
and that's the old school term for movies,
but it literally is what it was.
Motion pictures was this film was showing you 30 pictures per second,
and it looks like motion,
even though you're just looking at images,
much like this flip book very quickly one after the other.
What about music?
Well,
how could you go about representing musical notes if again
your only ingredients are zeros and ones.
Even if you're not a musician,
how do you represent music like that on the screen here?
Yeah.
OK,
so the frequency,
like the tone that you're actually hearing
from the device,
what else might weigh in beside besides the frequency of the notes?
Yeah.
So the speed of the note,
maybe the duration,
like if you think about a physical piano,
like how long you're holding the key down for or not,
what else?
So the amplitude may be how loud,
like how hard did you hit the keyboard to generate that sound.
So let me propose at the risk of simplifying,
we could represent each of these notes using 3 numbers,
maybe 0 to 255 or some other range that
represents the frequency or the pitch of the note.
Duration and the loudness and so long as the person receiving a file containing all
of those zeros and ones knows how to interpret them three at a time,
I bet you could share
a musical file with someone else that they could hear in exactly the same way
that you yourself intended.
Let me pause here
to see
if there's any questions now because we've already built
our way up from zeros and ones now to
video
and sound.
Yeah,
in front.
What the letter like 65 would be and then the number 5.
So how does the computer distinguish between the letter 65 and the number 65?
It's context dependent.
So
put simply,
and we'll see this as early as next week,
the programmer tells the computer
how to display the information either as a number or a letter
or equivalently once.
Programmed,
the software knows that when it opens a dot GIF file or jpayEG or
something else to interpret those zeros and ones as colors instead of as like.
DOCX for Microsoft Word file
or the like.
Other questions.
On any of these representations,
yeah,
in front like the 1 thing like really briefly.
Sure,
so can we go on base 10 and base 2?
So base 10 is like literally the numbers you and I use every day.
It's base 10 in the sense that you have 10 digits at your disposal,
0 through 9,
and any numbers you want to represent in the
real world must be composed using 0 through 9.
The binary system or base 2 is fundamentally the same.
It's just the.
doesn't have access to 2
through 9.
It only has access to 0 and 1.
But much like the light bulbs I was displaying here,
you can simply ascribe different weights
to each of the digits so that instead of it being as much as the one's place,
the tens place,
and the hundreds place,
if we more modestly say the one's place,
the two's place,
the four's place,
we can.
The same system
in binary you might need to use more digits to count
as high because in 255 you can just write 255.
That's 3 digits in decimal.
But in binary we've seen you need to use 8 such digits,
which is more,
but it's still much better than unary,
which would have had 255 light bulbs on.
Instead.
And they like.
Is binary and base 2 the same thing?
Yes,
just like base 10 and decimal are the same thing as well,
and unary and base 1
are the same thing as well.
All right,
so let me just stipulate that even though we sort of
took this tour quickly at the end of the day,
computers only have zeros and ones at their disposal.
So again,
the answer to any question is to how can we represent.
X is going to somehow involve permuting those zeros and ones
into patterns or equivalently into the numbers that they represent.
But if we now have a way to represent all inputs in the world,
be it letters,
numbers,
images,
videos,
anything else,
and get output from some problem solving process,
like how do we actually solve problems?
Well,
the secret sauce in the middle here is another term
that you've probably heard in the real world nowadays,
which is that of algorithm.
step by step instructions for solving some problem.
So this ultimately is what computer science really is about too.
It's not just representing information but somehow processing it,
doing something interesting with it to actually solve the problem that you've
been provided as input so you can output the correct answer.
Now there's all sorts of algorithms implemented in
our phones and in our Macs and PCs,
and that's all software is.
It's an implementation in.
Code,
be it C++ or Java or anything else,
other languages exist too
in
code that the computer understands,
but it's still just step by step instructions.
And among the things we'll learn in CS 50 is how to express yourself in different
ways to solve problems not only in different
languages but using different methodologies as well,
because as we'll see,
among the reasons we introduced these several languages is
you don't just learn more and more languages.
They allow you to solve the same problems.
Different languages will allow you to solve different problems and even
save you time by being better tools for the job.
So here,
for instance,
on an iPhone is maybe a bunch of contacts,
which is presumably familiar where we might have a whole bunch of
friends and family and whatnot alphabetized by first name or last name.
And suppose we want to find one such person like John Harvard,
whose number here might be + 1 94946.
82,750.
Feel free to call or text him sometime.
This is the goal of this problem.
If we have our contacts app and I start typing
in John's name by first name or last name,
the autocomplete nowadays kicks in and it somehow filters the list down from my 10
or 100 friends or 1000 friends into just the single directory entry that matches.
So here too,
back in the days of RG&B.
Projectors we had phone books like this here too.
I'm pleased to say thanks to our friend Alexis,
this is the largest phone book that we've used for this demonstration.
This is an old school phone book that's essentially the
same thing as our contacts app or address book nowadays,
whereby I've got a whole bunch
of names and numbers alphabetically sorted by first name or last name,
whatever,
and corresponding to each of those as a number.
So back in the day,
and frankly even nowadays in your phone.
How do you go about finding someone in a phone book or your contacts app?
Well,
you could very naively just start at the beginning
and look down and just turn one page at a time looking for John Harvard in this case.
Now,
so long as I'm paying attention,
this step by step process
will get me to John Harvard.
Like this is a correct algorithm,
even though you might kind of object to how I'm doing this,
why,
what's bad about this algorithm?
It's just slow.
I mean this is crazy slow.
If there's like 1000 pages in the songbook,
which looks like there are like this could take me as
many as 1000 pages or maybe he's roughly in the middle,
it's like 500 pages.
Like that's crazy.
That's really rather slow,
especially if I'm going to do this again and again.
Well,
what if I do it a little smarter grade school,
I sort of learned how to count 2 at a time,
so 2468,
1012,
1416,
18.
Again,
if I'm paying attention,
I'll get there twice as fast because I'm counting 2 at a time,
but is that algorithm step by step correct?
And I'm seeing no,
but why?
I might skip over John Harvard.
So just by bad luck and kind of with 50/50 probability,
he's going to be sandwiched between two of the pages.
Now I don't have to abort this algorithm altogether.
I could just,
as soon as I get past the J section if we're doing it by first name,
I could just double back one page and just make sure that I haven't missed him.
So it's recoverable and this algorithm therefore is sort of twice as fast.
Mm,
plus one extra step maybe to double back,
but that's arguably otherwise a bug or a mistake
in the algorithm if I don't fix it intelligently.
But what did we do back in the day and what does your iPhone or Android phone do?
What they typically do is they go roughly to the middle,
look physically or virtually down,
they see,
oh,
I'm in the M section,
and so which side is John Harber to,
to the left or to the right?
So he's to the left,
so I could literally now.
Jesus Christ.
We talked about this before class and this might be more,
oh my God.
There we go.
We can tear the problem in half.
Thank you.
It's been a while.
Uh,
we can tear the problem in half.
We know that John Harvard is to the left,
so I can throw
half of the problem away if,
uh,
dramatically,
such that I'm now going to from a 1000 page problem
to 500 pages instead.
What now can I do?
I can go roughly to the middle here and maybe I'm in the E section.
So I went a little too far back to the left,
but I kept it simple and I just divided
so that I can conquer this problem,
if you will.
And if I'm in the E section now,
is John Harvard to the left or to the right?
To the right,
so I can get,
Jesus.
Tear the problem in half,
and now,
thank you.
So now John Harvard again is going to be in this half.
I can throw this half away.
So now I've gone from 1000 to 500 to 250,
and I can repeat,
repeat,
down to 125,
half of that,
so I'm left with finally
just a single page.
And John Harvard is hopefully now on this page such that I can call him
or not at all,
at which point this is.
All sort of for naught,
but what's powerful about each of those algorithms is that the sort of good,
better,
and best.
Like they all get the job done,
conditional on the second one having that little fix just to
make sure I don't miss John Harber between two pages,
but they're fundamentally different in their efficiency
and the quality of their design.
And this is really representative of one of the emphases of a class like this.
It's not just about writing correct code or getting the job done,
but doing it well and doing it quickly,
using the least amount of CPU or computing resources,
using the minimal amount of RAM,
using the fewest number of people
using the least amount of money,
whatever your constrained resource is,
solving a problem better.
So that first algorithm,
step by step instructions,
was all about doing something
like this whereby.
The first algorithm,
if we plot things on a grid like this,
we have on the x axis a representation of the size of the problem.
So this would mean small problem like 0 pages.
This would mean big problem like 1000 pages,
and then the Y or vertical axis we have some measurement of time.
So this is the number of seconds or the number of page turns,
whatever you're.
Metric actually is,
so this would be not much time at all,
so fast this would be a lot of time,
so slow.
So what's the relationship if we just roughly draw these three algorithms?
Well,
the first one is technically a straight line,
and we'll describe that as n.
The slope is N because if you think of N as a number for the number of pages,
well,
there's a 1 to 1 relationship.
And the first algorithm as to how many times I have to turn the page
based on how many pages there actually is,
and you can think about this in the extreme.
If I was looking for someone whose name started with Z,
I might have to go through like 1000 darn pages
to get to that person whose name started with Z
unless again I do something hackish and just kind of cheat and go to the end.
If we execute these algorithms again and again in the same way,
that's going to be pretty slow.
But the second algorithm was.
Pretty much twice as fast plus that one extra step potentially,
but it's still a straight line because if there's 1000 pages
and I'm dividing the problem and doing two pages at a time,
well,
that's like N divided by 2 steps plus 1,
give or take.
But it's still a straight line because,
but it's still better.
Notice if this is the size of the problem,
1000 pages for instance,
we'll notice that the first algorithm took literally twice as much time.
As the second algorithm,
so we're doing better already,
but the third algorithm fundamentally
is going to look something like this.
And if you remember your logarithms,
so to speak,
sort of the opposite of an exponential,
this curve
is so much
lower and flatter,
if you will,
than either of these two.
Mathematically,
more on this another time,
the slope is going to be like log based 2 of N or just logarithmic in nature,
but what it means is that it's growing very.
Very,
very,
very slowly.
It's still going up.
It's never going to flat line and go perfectly horizontal,
but it goes up very slowly.
Why?
Well,
if you think about two towns nearby like Cambridge on this side
of the river and the town of Alston on the other,
suppose that they still have phone books like this one and they merge
their phone books for whatever reason.
So overnight we go from a 1000 page phone book to a 2000 page phone book.
The first algorithm is going to take literally twice as long.
As well the second one because we're only going through it 1 or 2 pages at a time,
but if the phone book size doubles
from this year,
for instance,
to next year,
you can kind of in your mind's eye think about the green line.
It's not going to go up
that much higher.
Why?
Well,
practically speaking,
even if the phone book becomes 2000 pages long,
well,
how many more times do you have to tear or divide that problem in half?
Just one because you're taking a 1000 page bye out of it or a 500 then a 250,
you're taking much bigger bytes out of it than just one or two at a time.
And so what computer science and what algorithms and about
good design is about is figuring out what is the logic
via which you can solve problems not only correctly but efficiently as well.
And that then gives us these things called algorithms.
And when it comes time to code,
which we're about to do too.
Code is just an implementation and a language the computer understands
of an algorithm.
Now this assumes that we've come up with some digital way,
that is to say 0 and 1 based way to represent names
and numbers,
but honestly we already did that.
We came up with the ASCI and then Unicode to represent the names,
and representing numbers is even easier than that.
That's really where we started.
So code is just about taking it.
Input some standardized representation of names and numbers and spitting out
answers and that's truly what iOS and Android are doing.
When you start doing autocomplete,
they could be searching from the top to the bottom,
which is fine if you've only got a few friends and family in the phone.
But if you've got 1000 or if you've got 10,000 or if it's not a phone book anymore,
it's some database with lots and lots of data.
Well it's.
to reason that it'd be nice maybe if the computer kept it
all alphabetized just like that book and jumped to the middle,
then the middle of the middle,
then the middle of the middle of the middle and so forth.
Why?
Because the speed is going to be much,
much faster,
logarithmic in nature and not linear,
so to speak,
in nature,
but we'll revisit those topics as well.
But for now,
before we get into actual code.
Let's talk for a moment about
pseudo code.
So pseudo code is not one formal thing,
but every human will come up with their own way of representing pseudo code.
It's an English-like or human-like formulation of
step by step instructions just using terse
correct
English or whatever human language.
So for instance,
if I want to translate what I did somewhat intuitively
with that phone book by just dividing in half,
dividing in half into step by step instructions,
I could hand.
Or nowadays like a robot or something like that.
Well,
step one was essentially to pick up the phone book,
which I did.
Step 2 was I opened to the middle of the phone book in the third and final algorithm.
Step 3 was look at the page as I did.
Step 4 got a little more interesting even though I didn't verbalize this.
Presumably I was asking myself a question.
If the person I'm looking for,
John Harvard,
is on the page,
then
I would have called him right then.
But if you weren't on the page,
if you instead were earlier in the book,
as did happen,
well then I'm going to go to the left,
so to speak,
but more methodically,
I'm going to open to the middle of the left half of the book.
Then I'm going to go back to
line 3.
That's interesting.
We'll come back to that in a moment,
but else if the person is later in the book,
well,
I'm going to open to the middle of the right half of the book
and then go back
to line 3.
Now,
let's pause here.
Why do I keep going back to line 3?
This would seem to get me doing the same thing
forever,
endlessly.
But not quite.
Why?
Yeah,
so because I am dividing the problem in half,
for instance,
on line 6 or line 9 implicitly just based on how I've written this,
the problem's getting smaller and smaller and smaller.
So it's fine if I keep doing the same logic
again and again because if the problem's getting smaller.
Eventually it's going to bottom out and I'm gonna have just
one person on that page that I want to call and so the algorithm's done.
But there is a perverse corner case,
if you will,
and this is where it's ever more important to be
precise when writing code and anticipate what could go wrong.
I should probably ask one more question in this code,
not just these three.
What might that
question.
Yeah.
Yeah,
so if John Harvard is not in the book,
there's this corner case where what if I'm just wasting my time entirely and
I get to the end of the phone book and John Harvard's not there,
what should the computer do?
Well,
as an aside,
if you've ever been using your Mac or PC or phone and the thing just freezes
or like the stupid little beach ball starts
spinning or something like that and you're like,
what is going on?
Some human at Google or Microsoft or Apple or the like made a mistake.
They forgot,
for instance,
that 4th uncommon but possible.
Situation wherein if they don't tell the computer how to handle it,
the computer's effectively going to freak out and do something
undefined like just hang or reboot or do something else.
So we do want to add this else
quit altogether.
So you have well defined behavior and truly think that the next time
your computer or phone spontaneously reboots or dies or does something wrong,
it's probably not your fault per se.
It's some other human elsewhere did not.
Correct code they didn't anticipate cases like these.
But now let's use some terminology here.
There's some salient ideas that we're going to see in scratch and
C and Python and these other languages I alluded to earlier.
Everything I've just highlighted here
henceforth we're gonna think of as functions.
Functions are verbs or actions that really get some small piece of work done for you.
Functions are verbs or actions.
Here though highlighted is the beginning of what we'll call.
Conditions,
conditionals like a fork in the road.
Do I go this way?
Do I go this way,
or some other way altogether?
How do you decide what road to go down?
We're going to call these questions you ask yourself
Boolean expressions,
named after a mathematician Bull,
and a boolean expression is just a question that has a yes or no
answer or a true or false answer or a 1 or zero answer.
Just it's a binary state,
yes or no typically.
Otherwise we have this go back to go back to,
which is what we're generally kind of
call a loop which somehow induces cyclical behavior
again and again
and those functions and those conditionals,
boolean expressions and loops and a few other concepts are pretty
much what will underlie all of the code that we write,
whether it is in
scratch,
C,
or something else altogether.
But we need to get to that point
and in fact,
let's go and.
Infer what this program here does.
At the end of the day,
computers only understand zeros and ones,
so I claim here is a program of zeros and ones.
What does it do?
Anyone want to guess?
I mean,
we could spend all day converting all of these zeros and ones to numbers,
but they're not gonna be numbers if it's code.
What do you think?
That's amazing.
It does in fact print
hello world.
All right,
so no one except like maybe you and me and a few others in the room should know,
and that's probably guess admittedly or advancing on the slide,
but why is that?
Well,
it turns out that not only do computers standardize information,
data like
numbers and letters and colors and other things,
they also standardize instructions.
And so if you've heard of companies like Intel or AMD or Nvidia or others,
among the things they do is they decide as a
company what pattern of zeros and ones shall represent what.
and it's very low level functionality.
Those companies and others
decide that some pattern of zeros and ones means
add two numbers together or subtract or multiply.
Another pattern might mean load information from
the computer's hard drive into memory.
Another might mean store it somewhere else.
Another might mean print something out to the screen.
So nested somewhere in here,
and admittedly I have no idea which pattern I'll find because it's
not interesting enough to go figure it out at this level,
says print.
And somewhere in there,
like this gentleman proposed,
I bet we could find the representation of H,
which was 72
and E and L and L and O and everything that
composes hello world because as it turns out in programming circles,
the very first program that students typically write
is that of hello world.
Now this one here
is written
in a much more intelligible way,
even if you're not a programmer,
odds are if I asked you what does this program do,
you would have said.
Oh hello world,
even though there's a lot of clutter here,
like no idea what this is until next week in main void that looks cryptic.
There's these weird curly braces which we rarely use in the real world,
but at least I understand a few words like hello and world,
and this is kind of familiar print F,
but it's not print,
but it's probably the same thing.
So here too is an example of this
hierarchy back in the day,
in the earliest days of computers,
humans were writing code by representing.
Zeros and ones.
If you've ever heard your parents talk about punch cards or the like,
you're effectively representing patterns that tell the computer what to do
or what to represent like literally holes and paper.
Well,
pretty quickly early on this got really tedious,
only writing code at such a low level,
so someone decided,
you know what,
I'm going to put in the effort.
I'm gonna figure out what patterns of zeros and ones I can put together
so as to be able to convert something more
user friendly.
To those zeros and ones and as a teaser for next week,
that person invented the first compiler.
A compiler is just a program that translates one language to another,
and more modernly,
this is a language called C which we'll spend
a few weeks on together because it's so fundamental
to how the computer works.
Even this is going to get tedious by like week 6 of the class,
and this is gonna get stupid,
this is gonna get annoying,
this is gonna get cryptic.
We're just gonna write print hello on the screen
in order to use a different language called Python.
Why?
Because someone wrote in C.
A program that can convert Python,
this is a white lie to C,
which can then be converted to zeros and ones and so forth.
So in computing there's this principle of abstraction
where we start with the basics and thank
God we can all trust that someone else
solved these really hard problems way long ago.
Then they wrote programs to make it easier.
We wrote programs to make it easier.
You can now write code like I did with the chatbot to make things even easier.
Why?
Because OpenAI and other companies have abstracted away a lot of the lower level.
Implementation details and that's where I think this stuff gets really exciting.
We can stand on the shoulders of others so long as we know how
to use and assemble these kinds of building blocks.
And speaking of building blocks,
let's start here.
Now odds are some of you might have started
here in like grade school playing with scratch,
and it's great for like after school programs,
learning how to program,
and you probably used it
this language to make games and graphics and just maybe playful.
Art or the like,
but in Scratch,
which is a graphical programming language designed about 20 years ago
from our friends down the road at MIT's Media Lab,
it represents pretty much everything we're going to
be doing fundamentally over the next several weeks in
more modern languages like C and Python,
more textual languages if you will.
I bet I could ask the group here what does this program do when you click a green flag.
Well,
it says
hello world on the screen,
because with Scratch,
you have the ability to express yourself with functions
and loops and conditionals and all of this,
but by using
drag and drop puzzle pieces.
So what we're about to do is this.
We're going to go on my screen to scratch.mit.edu.
It's a browser-based programming environment,
and we're only going to spend one week,
really a few days in CS 50 on this language,
but the overarching goal is to one,
make sure everyone's comfortable applying some
of these building blocks and actually.
Developing something that's interesting and visual and audio as well,
but to also give us some visuals that we can rely on and fall back on
when all of those curly braces and parentheses and
sort of stupid syntax comes back that's necessary in
many languages but can very quickly become a distraction
early on from the interesting and useful ideas.
So what we're about to see is this in a browser.
This is the scratch programming environment and there's
a few different parts of this world.
This is the blocks palette,
so to speak.
Uh,
that is to say there's a bunch of puzzle pieces or building blocks that represent
functions and conditionals and and uh loops and other such constructs.
There's going to be the programming area here where you can
actually write your code by dragging and dropping these puzzle pieces.
There's a whole.
whole world of sprites here by default scratch is
and is a cat by design,
but you can make scratch look like a dog,
a bird,
a garbage can,
or anything else,
as we'll soon see.
And then this is the world in which Scratch itself lives.
So Scratch can go up,
down,
left,
right,
and generally be animated within that world.
For the curious,
kind of like high school geometry class,
there's sort of this XY plane here,
so 00 would be in the middle,
0 180 is here,
0.
180 is here.
Uh,
-240,
0 is here,
and 240 0 is here.
Generally you don't need to worry about the numbers,
but they exist so that when you say up or down,
you can actually tell the program go up one pixel or 10 pixels
or 100 pixels so that you have some definition of what this world
actually is.
All right,
so let's actually put this to the test.
Let me go ahead here and flip over to in just a moment.
The actual Scratch website
whereby
I'm gonna have on my screen in just a moment,
that same user interface,
once I've logged in.
That via which I can actually write some code of my own.
Let me go ahead and zoom in on the screen a little
bit here and let's make the simplest of these programs first.
Maybe a program that simply says he world.
Now at a glance,
it's kind of overwhelming how many puzzle pieces there are,
and honestly,
even over 20 years I've never used them all,
and MIT occasionally adds to it.
But the point is that they're color coded
to resemble the type of functionality that they offer
and also it's meant to be the sort of thing where you can.
Kind of scroll through
and get a visual sense of like what you could do and
then figure out how you might assemble these puzzle pieces together.
So I'm going to go under this yellow or orangeish category here to begin with.
So there exists in the world of Scratch,
not quite the same jargon that I'm using now functions
and conditionals and loops that's more of the programmer's way.
This is more of the child friendly way,
but it's really the same idea
under events.
You have puzzle pieces that represent things that can happen
while the world is running.
So for instance,
the first one here is sort of the canonical when the green flag is clicked.
Why is that relevant?
Well,
in the two dimensional world that Scratch lives in,
there's a stop sign which means stop,
and there's a green flag which means go.
So I can therefore drag one of these puzzle pieces
over here so that when I click that green flag,
the cat will in fact do something for me.
Doesn't really matter where I drop it so long as it's somewhere in the middle here.
I'm gonna go ahead and let go.
Now I want the look of the cat to change.
I want to see like a cartoon speech bubble come out for now,
so I'm going to go under looks here
and there's a bunch of different ways to say things and think things.
I'm gonna Keep it simple and just drag this one here.
And now notice when I get close enough to that first puzzle piece,
they're sort of magnetic and they want to snap together so I
can just let go and boom because they're a similar shape,
they will lock together automatically
and notice too if I zoom in here.
The white oval,
which by default says hello,
is actually editable by me because it
turns out that some functions can take arguments
or more generally inputs that influence their behavior.
So if I kind of click or double click on this,
I can change it to the more canonical
Hello world or hello David or hello,
whatever I want the message to be.
I'm going to go ahead and zoom out and now over here at
top right notice that I can very simply click the green flag and
I'll have written.
My first program in Scratch.
I clicked the green flag.
It said go and now notice it's sort of stuck
on that because I never said stop saying go,
but that's where I can click the red stop sign and
sort of get the cat back to where I want it.
So think about for just a moment
what it is we just did.
So at the one hand we have a very obvious
puzzle piece that says say and it said something,
but
it really is a function,
and that function does take an input
represented by the white oval here.
Otherwise known as an argument or a parameter,
but what this really is is just an input to the function.
And so we can map even this simple,
simple scratch program onto our model of problem solving before with
an addition of what we'll call moving forward a side effect.
A side effect in a computer program is often something that happens
visually on the screen or maybe audibly out of a speaker.
It's something that just kind of happens as a result of you
using a function like a speech bubble appearing on the screen.
So here more generally is what we claimed it represents the solving
of a problem and let's just consider what the input is.
The input to this problem,
say something on the screen,
is this white oval here that I typed in Hello world,
the algorithm,
the step by step instruction.
are not something really I wrote like our friends
at MIT implemented that purple say block so someone there
knows how to get the cat to say something out of its
comical mouth.
So the algorithm implemented in code is really equivalent to the say function.
So a function is just a piece of functionality
implemented in code.
Which in turn implements an algorithm.
So algorithm is sort of the concept
and the function is actually the incarnation of it in code.
What's the output?
Well,
hopefully it's the side effect,
seeing the speech bubble come out of the cat's mouth like this.
All right,
so that's
one such program,
but it's always gonna play and look the same.
What if I actually want to prompt the human
for their actual name?
Well,
let me go back to the puzzle pieces here.
Let me go ahead and throw this whole thing away,
and if you want to delete blocks,
you can either right click or control click and choose from a menu,
or you can just drag them there and sort of let go,
and they'll disappear.
I'm going to go back in and get another,
another event block,
even though I could have reused that same one.
I'm going to go ahead and go under sensing now,
and if I zoom in over here,
you'll see a whole bunch of things like I can sense distance and colors,
but more pragmatically I can use this function in blue.
Ask something
and then wait for the answer.
And what's different about this puzzle piece is that it
too is just a function it too takes an argument,
but instead of having an immediate side
effect like displaying something on the screen,
it's essentially
inside of the computer going to hand me back the response.
It's going to return a value,
so to speak,
and a return value is something that the code can see,
but the human can't.
A side effect is something the human sees,
but a return value is something only the computer sees.
It's like the computer is handing me back
the user's input.
So how does this work?
Well,
notice,
and this is a bit strange,
this isn't usually how variables work,
but scratch 2 supports variables,
and that was a word I used quickly at the very start when we were making the chatbot,
a variable like in math,
X,
Y,
or Z just stores some value,
but it doesn't have to store a number in code it can store like a human name.
So what's going to happen when I use this puzzle piece is
that once the human types in their name and hits enter,
MIT,
or really scratch,
is going to store the answer,
the so-called return value,
in a variable that's designed to be called answer.
But as we'll see,
you can make your own variables down the line
if you want and call them anything you want.
But let me go ahead and zoom out.
Let me drag this over here.
I'm going to use the default question What's your name?
But I could certainly change the text there
and let me go under looks again.
Let me go ahead and grab the say block
and let me go ahead and say just for consistency like hello,
comma,
OK,
and now let me go under maybe sensing.
I want to say
how do I wanna say this answer.
Well,
notice this the shapes are important.
This too is an oval,
even though it's not white,
but that's just because it's not editable.
It's gonna be handed to me
by the As function.
Let me zoom out and grab a second
say block
like this,
and notice it will magnetically clip together.
I don't want to say hello again so I could delete that,
but
now it's still the same shape even though it's a little smaller.
Let me go back to sensing and notice what can happen here.
When you have values like words inside of a so-called variable,
you can use those instead of manual input at your keyboard
and notice it you wants the magnetic slap into place,
it'll grow to fit that variable because the shape is the same.
And now let's do this.
Let me click the green flag at right.
I'm seeing quote unquote,
what's your name,
I'm getting a text box this time,
like on a
web page,
for instance,
let me type in my name and watch closely what comes out of
the cat's mouth as soon as I click the checkmark or hit enter.
Huh,
OK,
I got my name right,
but let me do it once more.
Let me stop and start.
D A V I D.
Enter
No,
it didn't work.
Let me try one other,
maybe it's my name.
Let's try Kelly.
Enter
what's missing obviously.
So the,
the hello,
there's a bug,
a mistake in this program,
but is there like what explains this even if you've never programmed before,
intuitively what could explain why I'm not seeing hello?
Exactly,
it's on two different lines,
so it's doing one after the other,
so it is happening.
It's just you and I as the slowest things in the room are just not
seeing it in time because it's happening so darn fast because my computer's so,
you know,
so new and so fast,
it's happening but way too quickly.
So how can we solve this?
Well,
can we solve this in a few different ways,
and this is where in Scratch,
at least for problems at zero when wherein you'll
have an opportunity to play around with it.
I can scroll around here and OK,
under control
I see something like weight,
so I can just kind of slow things down and now notice too,
if you hover over the middle of two blocks,
if it's the right shape,
it'll just snap into the middle too or
you can just so you know,
kind of drag things away to magnetically separate them,
but this might solve this,
so let me hit stop and then start.
DAVID enter.
Hello
David.
All right,
that was a little,
let's do like maybe 2 seconds to see it again.
Green flag,
D A V I D E.
hello
David.
All right,
it's working better.
It's sort of more correct because I'm seeing the hello and the David,
but kind of stupid,
right,
to see one
and then the other.
Wouldn't it be nice to say it all in one breath,
so to speak?
Well,
here's where we can maybe compose some ideas.
So let me get rid of this weight and the additional block.
Let's confine our.
in just one block,
but let me go down to operations
where we haven't been before,
and this is interesting.
There's this bigger oval here that says join two things like apple and banana,
and those are just random placeholder words that
you can override with anything you want,
but they're both ovals and white,
which means I can edit them.
So let me go ahead and do this.
Let me drag this on top of the save block,
and this is just gonna therefore uh override
the hello I put there.
Now I don't wanna say apple or banana,
but I do want to say hello,
comma.
And I then want to say my name.
OK,
so now I can go back to sensing,
go back to answer,
drag and drop this here.
That'll snap into place and let me zoom in.
Now what I've done is take a function and on top of it I nested another function,
the join function that takes two arguments or inputs
and presumably joins them together as per its name.
So let's see what this does for us.
Let me click stop and start.
I'll type in David,
Enter.
And it's so close.
Now this is just kind of an aesthetic bug.
What have I done wrong here?
There's no space,
so it looks a little wrong,
but that's an easy fix.
I just need to literally go into the hello block after the comma,
hit the space bar so that now when I stop and start again and type in David,
now I see something that's closer to the grammar
we might typically expect syntactically here.
All right,
so let's model this after
what we just saw earlier.
We've now introduced a so-called return value.
And this return value is something we can then use in the way we want.
It's not happening immediately like the speech bubble.
It's clearly being passed to me in some way
that I can use to plug in somewhere else,
like into that join block.
So if we consider the role of these variables playing,
let's consider the picture now as follows.
If the input now to the first function,
the ask block,
is what's your name,
quote unquote,
that's indeed being fed into the ask.
Block and the result this time is not a speech bubble.
It's not some immediate visual side effect.
It is the answer itself stored in a
so-called variable as represented by this blue oval.
Meanwhile,
what I want to do is combine that answer with some text I
came up with in advance by kind of stacking these things together.
Now visually in scratch,
you're stacking them on top,
but it's really.
You're passing one into the other into the
other because much like math when you have the
parentheses and you're supposed to do what's inside
the parentheses and then work your way out,
same idea here.
You want to join hello and answer together and whatever that output is,
that then becomes the input to the say block which
like in math is outside of the joined block itself.
So pictorally it might now look like this.
There's two inputs to this story.
Hello,
space and the answer variable.
The puzzle piece in question is joined.
Its goal in life had better be to give me the full phrase that I want,
hello David.
Let's shift everything over now because that output is
about to become the input to the say block,
which itself will now have the so-called side effect.
And so this too is what programming and in turn what computer science is about is.
Posing with the solutions to smaller problems,
solutions to bigger problems using those component pieces,
and that's what each of these puzzle pieces represents is a smaller problem
that someone else or maybe even you,
has already solved.
Now we can kind of spice things up here if I go back to
scratches interface,
we don't have to use just the puzzle piece here.
I can do something like this.
Let me go ahead and drag these apart and get rid of the same block down here.
Just for fun,
there's all these extensions that you can add over the internet
to your own scratch environment,
and if I go to like text to speech down here,
I can for instance do a speak block instead of a say block color here in green.
I can now reconnect the join block in here and
if we could raise the volume just a little bit,
let me stop the old version,
start the new version,
type in my name and hear what Scratch actually sounds like.
Hello
David.
OK,
not very catlike,
but we can kind of waste some time on this by like dragging the set voice to box,
and I can put this anywhere I want
above
the speak block.
So I'm just going to put it here,
even though I've already asked a question.
Maybe kitten sounds appropriate.
Let's try again.
D A V I D,
meow meow.
OK,
and then let's see,
uh,
giant,
a little creepier,
here we go,
DAVID and lastly.
Hello,
David.
All right,
little ransom like instead.
so that's just some additional puzzle pieces,
but really just the same idea,
but I like that we've introduced some sounds.
So let's do this.
Let me go ahead and throw away a lot of those puzzle pieces,
leave ourselves with just the one green flag clicked.
And play around with some other
building blocks that we've seen already thus far.
Let me go ahead,
for instance,
under sound,
and let's make the cow actually meow.
So it turns out scratch,
being a cat by default comes with some sounds by default like meowing.
So if we go ahead and click the green flag after programming this
program,
let's hear what he sounds like now.
OK,
kind of cute,
and if you want it scratch to meow twice,
you can just play the game again.
And a third time,
Alright,
but that's gonna get a little tedious,
as cute as it is,
so I can solve that.
Let's just grab 3 of the puzzle pieces and
just drag them together and let them connect,
and now click the green flag.
All right,
doesn't,
it gets less cute quickly,
but maybe we can slow it down
so that the cat doesn't sound so,
so hungry maybe.
Let me go under,
uh,
let's see,
under control,
let's grab one of those,
wait one second,
and maybe plop a couple of these in the middle here,
that might help things,
and now click the green flag.
OK,
still a little hungry,
but let's see if we change it to 2,
and then I change it to 2 down here in both places,
let's play it again.
OK,
cuter,
maybe.
But now I'm venturing into badly programmed territory.
This is correct.
If my goal is to get the cat to meow 3 times,
pausing in,
sorry,
3 times,
pausing in between,
what is
bad about this code,
even if you've never programmed before though?
Yeah,
in the middle.
I literally had to repeat myself 3 times,
essentially copy pasting,
and frankly I could have been really lazy and I could right click or control click,
and I could have chosen duplicate,
but generally when you copy paste code or when you duplicate puzzle pieces,
probably doing something wrong.
Why?
It's solving the problem correctly,
but it's not well designed,
even if for only because when I changed the number of seconds,
now I had to change it in two places.
So I had one.
Initially,
then I had to change it to 2,
and if you just imagine in your mind's eye having not like 6 puzzle pieces,
but 60 or 600 or 6000,
you're going to screw up eventually if it's on you to
remember to change something here and here and here and here,
like you're going to mess up.
It's better to keep things simple and ideally centralized
by factoring out common functionality and clearly playing sound
and waiting is something I'm doing at least twice,
if not a third time here as well.
So how can we do this better?
Well,
remember this thing.
Loops.
Maybe we can just do something a little more cyclically.
So I tell the computer to do something once,
but I tell it how many times
to do that altogether.
So notice here by coincidence under control I
have a repeat block which doesn't say loop,
but that's certainly the right semantics.
Let me go ahead and drag the repeat block in and
I'll change the 10 to 3 just for consistency here.
I'm going to go back to sound.
I'm going to go ahead and play sound.
Meow until done just as before and just so it's not meowing too fast under control,
I'm going to grab a wait one second and keep it inside the loop
and notice that the loop here is sort of hugging these puzzle pieces by growing
to fill however many pieces I actually cram in there.
So now if I click play,
the effect is going to be the same,
but it's arguably not only correct but also
well.
Designed,
because now if I wanna change the weight,
change it in one place,
if I want to change the total number of times,
so I've modularized the code
and made it better designed in this case,
but now this is silly because,
Even
though
I want the cat to meow,
it feels like any program in which I want this cat to meow,
I have to make these same puzzle pieces and connect them together.
Wouldn't it be nice to invent the notion of meowing
once and then actually have a puzzle piece called meow?
So when I want the cat to meow,
it will just
meow.
Well,
I can do that too.
Let me scroll down to my blocks.
Here in pink I'm going to click Make a block and I'm
going to literally make a new puzzle piece that MIT didn't think of
called meow and I'm going to go ahead and click OK.
Now I have in my code area here a define block,
which literally means define meow as follows.
So how am I going to do this?
Well,
I'm going to propose that me.
Ming just means to play the sound,
meow until done,
and then wait 1 2nd.
And notice now I have nothing inside my actual program
which begins when I click the green flag,
but notice at top left because I made a block called meow,
I now have access to one that I can drag and drop.
So now I can drag meow into.
This loop
and per my comment about abstracting the lower level implementation details away,
I'm going to sort of unnecessarily dramatically just move that out of the way.
It still exists.
I didn't delete it,
but now out of sight,
out of mind.
Now if you agree with me that meow means for the cat to make a sound,
we've abstracted away what it means.
Mechanically
for the cow to say
that sound
and so we now have our own puzzle piece that I can
just now use forever because I invented the meow block already.
Now I can do one better than this.
It would be nice if I could just tell the meow block how many times I
wanted to meow because then I don't need to waste time using loops either myself.
So let me do this.
Let me zoom out.
And let me go back to my defined block.
Let me right click or control click and just edit it,
or I could delete it and start over,
but I'll just edit it
and specifically let me say,
you know what,
let's add an input,
otherwise known as an argument to this meow block,
and we'll call it maybe N from the number of times I want it to meow.
And just to be super clear,
I'm going to add a label which has no functional impact,
but it just helps me remember what this does.
So I'm going to say meow and time.
So that when I see the puzzle piece,
I know what the N actually represents.
If I now click OK,
my puzzle piece looks a little different at top left.
Now it has the white oval into which I can type or drag input.
Notice down here in the defined block,
I now see that same
input called N.
So what I can do now is this.
Let me go under control,
drag the repeat block here,
and I have to do a little switcheroo.
Let me disconnect this.
Plug it inside of the repeat block,
reconnect all of this,
and I don't want 10,
and heck,
I don't even want 3 down here anymore.
I can drag this input because it's the right shape
and now declare
that meowing end times means to repeat the
following end times play sound meow until done.
Wait 1 2nd and keep doing that and total times.
If I now zoom out and scroll up.
Notice that my usage of this puzzle piece has changed
such that I don't actually need the repeat block anymore.
I can disconnect this
and heck,
I can actually right click and
control click and delete it.
Just use this under the green flag,
change this to a 3,
and now
I have the essence of this meowing program.
The implementation details are out of sight,
out of mind.
Once they're correct,
I don't need to worry about them again,
and this is exactly.
Scratch itself works.
I have no idea how MIT implemented the weight block or the repeat block.
Heck,
there's a forever block,
and there's a few others,
but I don't need to know or care because they've
implemented those building blocks that I can then implement myself.
I don't necessarily know how to build a whole chatbot,
but on top of OpenAIs,
API,
this web-based service,
I can implement my own chatbot because they've done the heavy lift of actually.
that
for me.
Well,
let's do just a few more examples here.
Let's bring the cat all the more to life.
Let me throw away the meowing.
Let me open up under when green flag clicked.
How about that forever block that we just glimpsed?
Let me go ahead and now add to the mix what we called earlier
conditionals which allow us to ask questions and
decide whether or not we should do something.
So under this,
let me go ahead and under Forever,
say if the following.
Is true.
Well,
what boolean expression do I want to ask?
let's implement,
how about this program and we'll figure out if it works.
Uh,
under sensing,
I'm gonna grab this,
uh,
a very angled puzzle piece called Touching mouse pointer that is the cursor,
and only if that question has a yes answer,
do I want to
play the sound meow until done.
So let me zoom in here and in English.
What
is this going to implement really?
Just describe what this program does less arcanely as the code itself,
yeah.
Yeah,
if you move the mouse over the cat,
it will make noise,
so it's kind of like implementing petting a cat,
if you will.
So let me zoom out,
click the green flag,
and notice nothing's happening yet,
but notice my puzzle pieces are highlighted in yellow because it is
in fact still running because it's
doing something forever and it's constantly checking
if I'm touching the mouse pointer,
and if so.
It's like I just pet the cat.
Now it stopped until I moved the cursor again.
Now it stopped.
If I leave it there,
it's gonna keep meowing because it's gonna be stuck in this loop forever,
but it's correct insofar as I'm petting the cat.
Let me do this though.
Let me make a mistake this time.
Let me forget about the forever and just do this,
and you might think this is correct.
Let me click the green flag.
Now let me pet the cat.
And like
nothing's actually working here.
Why though logically.
Yeah.
Yeah,
the program's so darn fast it already ran through the sequence and
at the moment in time when I clicked the rear flag,
no,
I was not touching the mouse pointer and so it was
too late by the time I actually moved the cursor there.
But by using the forever block,
which I did correctly the first time,
this ensures that Scratch is constantly checking the answer to that question.
So if and when I do pet the cat,
it will
actually
Detect as much.
All right,
about a few final examples before you're on your way building
some of your own first programs with these building blocks.
Let me go ahead and open up a program
that I wrote in advance,
in fact,
about 20 years ago,
whereby,
let me pull this up.
Whereby we have in this example a program I wrote called Oscar time,
and this was the result of our first assignment in this class whereby
when MIT was implementing Scratch for the very first time,
we needed to implement our very own Scratch program as well.
I'm gonna go ahead and full screen it here.
The goal is to drag as much falling trash as
you can to Oscar's trash can before his song ends,
for which one volunteer would be handy here.
OK,
so.
Hands go up quickly in blue.
Yeah,
come on up.
All right,
so
you're playing for a stress ball here if we will.
At one at some point I'm going to talk over
what you're actually playing just so that we can point out
what it is we're trying to glean from this program,
and I'll stipulate this probably took me like 8,
12 hours,
and as you'll soon see,
the song starts to drive you nuts after a while because I was trying to
synchronize everything in the game to a childhood
song with which you might be familiar.
Let me go ahead and say hello if you'd like to introduce yourself.
Oh,
hello.
So I'm Han.
And uh I'm a first year student.
I'm pretty excited for this class.
welcome.
Well,
here is Oscar time.
If you want to go ahead and take control of the keyboard,
all you'll need to do is drag and drop trash that falls from the sky
into the trash can.
Oh
Anything score is 1.
Nice score 2.
All right,
let's see what happens.
You'll see a sneaker was perfectly timed.
Thank you very much with the song after figuring
out exactly how many seconds it had to wait.
Now Han can drag not only the piece of trash,
but the shoe as well.
And it's around this point in the game where
the novelty starts to wear off because it's like
3 more minutes of this game where more and more stuff starts to fall from the sky.
So as Han,
as you continue to play,
I'm going to cut over.
Here you keep playing.
Let's consider how I implemented this
whereby
we'll start at the beginning.
The very first thing I did when implementing Oscar time honestly was the easy part.
Like I found a lamppost that looked a little something like this,
and I made the so-called costume for the whole stage,
and that was it.
The game didn't do anything.
You couldn't play anything.
You click the green flag,
nothing happened.
But then I figured out how to turn the scratch cat,
otherwise known more generally as a sprite,
into a trap.
instead and so the trash can meanwhile is
clearly animated because I realized that oh,
I can give sprites like the cat different costumes so I
can make the cat not only look like a trash can,
but if I want its lid to go up,
well,
that's just another costume.
And if I want to see Oscar popping out,
that's just a third costume.
And so I made my own simplistic animation
and you can kind of see it.
It's very jittery step by step by step
by creating.
illusion of animation by really just having a
few different images or costumes on Oscar.
I hope you appreciate how much effort went
involved into timing each of these pieces of
trash with the specific mention of that type of piece of trash in the music.
OK,
20 years later,
still clinging.
So you're doing amazing,
by the way.
How do we get the trash to fall in the first place?
Well,
at the very beginning of the game,
the trash just started falling from some random location.
What does it mean for trash to fall from the sky?
Oh,
big climax here.
So you've got a lot of trash on the ground you should pick up.
There we go,
and your final score is.
A big round of applause if we go for hot.
OK.
Thank you.
So
just to be clear,
now let's decompose this fairly involved program that took me
a lot of hours to make into its component parts.
So this is just a sprite,
and I figured out eventually how to change its costume,
change its costume,
change its costume to simulate some kind of animation.
And I also realized that oh,
I don't need to just have one Sprite or one cat or trash can.
You can create a 2nd Sprite,
a 3rd Sprite,
and many more.
So I just told the Sprite to go to a random location
at Y equals 180 and X equals something.
I think I restricted X to be in this region,
which is why the trash never falls from over here.
I just a little bit of math based on that
Cartesian plane that we saw a slide of earlier.
And then
I probably had a loop that told the trash to move a pixel,
move a pixel,
move a pixel down,
down,
down until it eventually hits the bottom and therefore just stops.
So we can actually see this step by step,
and this is representative of how even for something like your
first problem set in CS 50 and with Scratch specifically,
you might build some of the same.
So I'm gonna go back into.
CS 50 Studio for today,
which is linked on the course's website which has
a few different versions of this and other programs
called Oscar 0 through Oscar 4,
where 0 is the simplest and truly I meant it
when I look inside this program to see my code,
like this was it.
There was no code because all I did was put the Sprite on the screen and change it
from a cat to a trash can and I Added a cost uh costume for the stage,
so to speak,
so that the lamp post would be fixated there.
If I then go to the next version of code,
version one,
so to speak,
then I had code that did this.
Now notice there's a few things going on here.
At bottom left,
you'll see,
of course,
the trash can,
and then at top right the trash.
Here are the corresponding sprites down here.
So When Oscar is clicked on here,
the trash can,
you see the code I wrote,
the puzzle pieces I dragged for Oscar,
and in a moment when we click on trash,
you'll see the code I wrote or the puzzle pieces I
wrote are dragged and dropped for the trash piece specifically.
So what does Oscar do?
Well,
I first switch his costume to Oscar one,
which I assume is this the closed trash can.
Then forever,
Oscar does the following.
If Oscar's touching the mouse pointer,
then change the costume to Oscar 2.
Otherwise,
that is,
if not touching the mouse pointer,
change the costume to Oscar one.
Well,
what's the implication?
Any time I move the cursor over the trash can,
the lid just pops up,
which was exactly the animation I wanted to achieve.
Meanwhile,
if we do this and click the green flag,
you can see that in action,
even for this simple.
If I move the cursor over Oscar,
we have the beginnings of a game,
even though there's no score,
there's no music or anything else,
but I've solved one of my problems.
Meanwhile,
if I click on the trash piece here
and then you'll see no code has been written for it yet.
So we move on to Oscar version 2 and see inside it.
And Oscar version 2,
when I click on trash,
ah,
now there's some juicy stuff happening here and in fact this
trash sprite has two programs or scripts associated with it,
and that's fine.
Each of them starts with when green flag clicked,
which means the piece of trash will do two things at once,
essentially in parallel.
The first thing it will do is we'll set drag mode to dragable,
and that's just a scratch thing that lets you
actually move the sprites by clicking on them,
making them.
Dragonable.
Then it goes to a random X location between 0
and 240.
So yeah,
that must be what I did from the middle all the way to the right,
and I said why always to 180,
which is why the trash always comes from the sky from the very top.
Then I said forever change your Y by -1,
and here's where it's useful to know what 180 is,
240 is,
and so forth,
because if I want the trash to go down,
so to speak,
that's.
Changing its Y
by a pixel by pixel,
by a pixel,
and thankfully MIT implemented it such that if the trash tries to go off the screen,
it will just stop automatically even if it's inside of a
forever block lest you lose control over the sprites altogether.
But in parallel what's happening is this
also when the green flag is clicked,
uh,
the trash piece is doing this too forever if touching Oscar,
what's it doing in blue here?
Sort of teleporting away now to your eye,
hopefully it looks like it's going into the trash can,
but what does that mean to go into the trash can?
Well,
I just put it back into the sky as though a new piece of trash is falling.
So even though you saw one piece of trash,
234,
and so forth,
it's the same sprite just acting that out again and again.
So here if I click play.
On this program
you'll see that it starts falling
one pixel at a time because it's draggable.
I can sort of pull it away
and move it over to the trash can like that,
and as soon as I do,
it seems to go in,
but really it just teleported to a different X location still at Y equals 180.
Again,
it's not much of a game yet.
There's no score,
there's no music or anything,
but let's go to Oscar 3 now.
And in Oscar 3,
if we scroll over to the trash,
even more is happening here and so.
As far as I realized,
you know what,
there was kind of inefficiency before.
Previously I had these two programs or scripts synonym
whereby they both went to the top by going to 0 to 240
for X and then 180 for Y.
And if you noticed,
I used that here
and I used that down here in both programs.
Now that was kind of stupid because I literally copied and pasted the same code.
So if I ever want to change that design,
I have to change it in two places and I already proposed that we frown upon that.
So what did I do in this version?
I just created my own block and I decided to call my own function
go to top.
What does it mean to go to the top,
pick a random X between those values,
and fixate on Y equals 180 initially.
Now in both of those programs,
which are otherwise identical,
I just say what I mean.
Go to top,
go to top,
and if I really wanted to,
I could drag this out of the way and
never think about it again because now that function.
exists,
so correct but arguably better designed.
I've now factored out commonality so as to use and reuse my code as well.
So let's go up to Oscar version 4 now,
and in Oscar time version 4,
the trashcan
does a little something more whereby
what have I added to this mix even though
we haven't dragged this puzzle piece together before.
Yeah,
what's new?
so it turns out on the left here there's a variables category which goes
beyond the answer variable that we just automatically get from the ask block.
You can create your own variables X,
Y,
Z,
but in computer programming it's best to name things,
not silly simple words like X,
Y,
and Z,
but full-fledged words that say what they are like score.
So I'm setting a score variable to 0,
and then any time
the trash is touching Oscar before it teleports away to the top,
I change the score by 1.
That is increment the score by 1.
And what Scratch does automatically for me is it puts
a little billboard up here showing me the current score.
So if I now
play this game
once more,
the score is going to start at 0.
But if I drag this trash over here and even let it fall in as soon as it touches,
the score goes to 1.
And now if I click and drag again,
the score is going to as soon as it touches Oscar,
going to go to 2,
and so forth.
And you saw in the final flurs with Hunt playing that
once you add The sound and other pieces of trash,
which are just really other sprites,
and I just had to wait like a minute,
wait 2 minutes,
so that the trumpet would fall at the right time.
I've broken down a fairly involved program
into these basic building blocks.
And when you two write your own program,
that's exactly how you should approach it,
even if you have these grand aspirations to do this or that,
start by the simple problems and figure out what bites can I,
uh,
bite off in order to make progress,
baby steps,
if you will,
to the final.
Solution.
Well,
let's look at one other set of examples before we have
one final volunteer to come up and as you'll soon see,
it's tradition in CS 50 to end the first class with cake.
So in a moment,
cake will be served out on the transept,
and please feel free to come up and say hi and ask questions if you'd like to.
Let me go ahead and open up though
a series of building blocks here via which we can make so-called IV's hardest game,
which is one implemented by one of your predecessors,
a former classmate
from CS 50.
So here we have a whole bunch of puzzle pieces.
Written by your classmates,
but let me go ahead and zoom in on this screen.
You'll see that this Harvard Crest is my sprite,
so it's not a cat,
it's not a trash can.
It's a Harvard Crest,
and it exists in a very simple
two-dimensional world with two walls next to it.
If I click on the green flag,
notice that
with my hands here,
I can go up,
I can go down,
I can go left,
and I can go right,
but if I try going too far right,
I get stuck on the wall.
If I go too far left,
Well,
it's the sort of the beginning.
Of any animation or game,
but how do I do this?
Well,
let me go up here and propose that the first thing
the Harvard Sprite is doing is it's going to the middle,
0.0,
and it's then forever
listening for the keyboard and feeling for walls.
Now those are functions I implemented myself to kind
of describe what I wanted the program to do.
And let's do the shorter one first.
What does it mean to feel for the walls?
Just to ask the question,
if you're touching the left wall,
change your X by 1.
If you're touching the right wall,
change your X by -1.
Why have I
defined touching walls in this weirdly mathematical way?
Yeah.
Sure,
yeah.
otherwise you're like net.
Exactly,
because if I've gone so far right that I'm touching the right wall,
well,
I'm already kind of on top of the wall a little bit.
So I effectively want the sprite to bounce off of it,
and the easiest way to do that is just to say
back up one pixel as though you can't go any further,
and same for the left wall.
Meanwhile,
let me scroll over to the second script or program that's running in parallel.
It's a little longer,
but it's not more.
Complicated.
What does it mean to listen for keyboard?
Well,
just check if the key
up arrow is pressed,
change Y by 1.
ergo go up,
else if the key down arrow is pressed,
then change Y by -1,
key right arrow is pressed,
change X by 1,
and so forth.
So again,
this is where the math and the numbers are useful because
it gives you a world in which to live up,
down,
left,
right.
Deconstructed into some simple arithmetic values.
All right,
so the net result is that we have a crest living in this world.
Well,
let's add a bit of competition here and then the second version of this game.
Let me go ahead and full screen it again,
click play,
and now we'll see
sort of an enemy
bouncing back and forth autonomously.
So there's no one playing except me.
I'm controlling Harvard,
Yale is bouncing on its own,
and nothing bad's.
Gonna happen if it hits me,
but
it does seem to be autonomous.
So how is this working?
Well,
if it's doing this forever,
there's probably a forever loop involved.
So let's see inside here.
Let's click not on Harvard but on the Yale Sprite,
and sure enough,
if we focus on this for a moment,
we'll see that the first thing Yale does is go to 0.0.
It points in direction 90 degrees,
which just gives you a sense of whether you're facing left or right or wherever.
Then it forever does the following.
If it's touching the left wall or touching the right wall,
I was a little clever this time,
if I may.
I just kind of turn around 180 degrees,
which effectively bounces me back in the opposite direction.
Otherwise I go ahead and no matter what,
just move one step.
And this is why Yale is always moving back and forth.
So a quick question,
if I wanted to speed up Yale and make this beginning of a game harder,
what would I do?
Yeah.
Yeah,
so let's have it move like 10 steps at a time,
right?
This looks like a much harder game if you will,
like level 10 now because it's just moving so much faster.
All right,
well,
let's try a third version of this that adds another ingredient.
Let me full screen this and click play,
and now you'll see the even smarter MIT
homing in on me
by following my actual movements.
So this is sort of like boss level material now.
And it's just gonna follow me.
So how is this working?
Well,
it's kind of a common game paradigm,
but what does this mean?
Well,
let's see inside here,
let's click on MIT Sprite,
it's pretty darn easy.
Go to some random position just to make it a little interesting lest MIT
always start in the center and then forever point towards the Harvard logo outline,
which is the name the former student gave to the costume
that the Sprite is wearing that looks like a Harvard crest,
and then move one step.
So a core layer of the previous question how do
we make the game harder and MIT even faster?
Well,
we can change this to be like 10 steps,
and now you'll see
MIT is a little twitchy because.
This is kind of a visual bug.
Let me make a full screen.
Why is this visual glitch happening?
It's literally doing what I told it to do,
just looks stupid,
yeah.
say like again.
Yeah,
it's moving so fast that it's sort of going 10 pixels this way,
but then I kind of,
it kind of overshot me,
so then it's doubling back to follow me again and it's doubling back this way.
And because these are such big footsteps,
if you will,
it just has this visual effect of twitching back and forth.
So we might have to throttle that back a bit and make it 5 or
2 or 3 instead of 10 because that's clearly not desirable gaming behavior here.
All right,
well,
let's go ahead and do this.
Let's put them all together just as your
former classmate did when submitting this actual homework.
Uh,
the game will conclude hopefully in an amazing climax where you've won the game,
so we need someone,
ideally with really good hand-eye coordination to play this final game here.
Yeah,
your hand went up first,
I think.
OK,
come on up,
big round of applause because it's a lot of pressure
to end.
All right,
so if you win the game,
cake will be served.
If you don't win the game,
there will be no cake.
OK,
but introduce yourself in the meantime.
Hi,
I'm Jenny Pan,
freshman at Hollis,
and I'm actually a CS major or concentration.
Nice to meet you.
Head to the keyboard here.
This now is the combination of all of those building blocks and even more,
AKA IB's hardest game,
you will be in control just as I would of the Harvard Crest,
and the goal is to make it to the exit,
which is this gentleman on the right here,
and you'll see there's multiple levels where each each level gets a little harder.
All right.
Here we go.
I can't touch this.
Very good.
Nicely done.
You can't touch this.
So the loop has been added for Yale.
Good.
2 Yales now.
Alright,
3 yals now.
Nice.
You can't touch this.
Here comes MIT.
Very
good,
yeah.
Two MITs.
And get
Nice,
yes.
That
I
Yes.
Now Princeton.
Another Princeton.
2nd to last level.
I
OK
Have a
Let's keep going,
keep going.
Yeah
All
right,
this is CS 15,
cake is now served.